si llegas
una vida digna de una película
o dos de hecho la reina isabel segunda
ha sido imagen de muchos de los
productores se sienten atraídos por los
períodos más oscuros de su vida familiar
como la muerte de la princesa diana
retratada en spencer o en la reina
película de 2006 que le valió a helen
mirren una buscar por su impactante
encarnación de la monarca
pero si se pregunta a los visitantes
fuera del palacio de buckingham la
referencia en la mayoría de sus mentes
es la exitosa serie de ground
la conocimos por ahora la respetamos
mucho más
pensar que una persona como mucho más
fría y a raíz de ver la película así que
me engancho muchísimo si es una forma
diferente de conocer a la realeza creo
que para los más jóvenes tener una serie
sólo puede ser beneficioso para las
actrices de la serie oliva colman y
claire foy mostrar la vida íntima de
isabel segunda fue un reto ya que rara
vez rompen su fachada pública
[Música]
para llegar a la verdad los productores
suelen recurrir a especialistas como
robert lazy que como investigador
estudia su vida anécdotas y secretos de
su entorno
la reina es esencialmente una persona
modesta por lo que tiene una aversión
instintiva a la publicidad sobre sí
misma y aunque es una persona
profesional y entiende que forma parte
de su trabajo no es algo que le guste
joyce en sus 70 años en el trono isabel
segunda sólo ha hecho una aparición en
el cine
[Aplausos]
pero sin duda causó impacto en el
cortometraje junto a daniel craig 007 la
reina ocupó portadas con un salto en
paracaídas en el estadio olímpico para
la ceremonia de apertura de los juegos
de londres-2012 una entrada triunfal y
un momento inolvidable en particular
para el doble de la monarca
así que esto fue en vivo sobre el
estadio yo salté primero seguido por un
amigo mío y luego esta soy yo aquí puedo
decirlo porque puedo ver el rosa del
maravilloso vestido que llevaba mi
vestido salmón melocotón
la escena fue vista en directo por más
de mil millones de personas dio una
pequeña muestra del sentido de humor de
la realeza y sin duda impulso la
popularidad de la reina en todo el mundo
un breve paso como protagonista en un
reinado recortado como monarca
[Música]